hey Leute und willkommen bei einer neuen
Folge t3c die letzte Folge war ja vor
zwei Tagen beim werten Herren mis Sparco
Phenix genau ich habe schon wieder
Diamanten gefunden den dritten hast de
Diamanten ja ich find hier übelst viel
weil das ist so ein richtiges Level das
mag ich weil ich bisher so selten
runtergefallen bin dass ist echt
unglaublich aber jetzt gerade das echt
wieder ein bisschen am am ruckeln
hier se aber jetzt gucken Spieß umdrehen
können der letzten Folge hast du ja
alles weg was nicht nagelfest war jetzt
gucken mal ob wir Spß umdrehen können
weil jetzt bei mir hier ne übelst lüssig
wieder na ja ich bin schon wieder
ziemlich weit ja das Problem ist ich
weiß gerade gar nicht wie es hier
weitergehen soll überhaupt das diese
reit Ding
rtergefallen ich ich spring die ganze
Zeit gegen die Seite von den Leitern D
nicht weiter kann ich überhaupt richtig
ja oder also ich bin gerade hier oben
hallo ja ich komme dir irgendwie nicht
weiter
komischerweise ja doch das ist
eigentlich relativ einfach also ich weiß
nicht was du da hast du bist wohl
einfach zu schlecht jetzt geht's oder
auch
nicht oder du bist einfach zu schlecht
ja ne nein ach Mist
ach so diese wohgere Aussprache Luca
Luca mein Gott
ach Gott schon wieder runtergefallen
jetzt bin ich auf deiner Höhe fast schon
oh du begibst dich auf mein Niveau
herunter ja bin ich nicht ein
netter ich komme jetzt nicht
hoch man bisher konnte ich das doch
eigentlich alles das wir übrigens mal
wieder ein toller Zeitpunkt für so ein
Thema wie gesagt ne also Themen einfach
in die Kommentare schreiben wenn ihr
welche wisst eben und wir konnten noch
nicht nachgucken weil es die gleiche
aufnahmession ist se dem let mal gefragt
habten
ja wir sind jetzt gerade schon die
fünfte Folge hier am aufnehmen
nein also das nein war nicht aufs
aufnehmen bezogen sondern auf einen
verkackten Sprung so Spark denk du dir
doch mal ein Thema aus ich glaube das
letzte Mal habe ich das Thema angestoßen
irgendwie mit dem Gewinnspiel ne nein
ich hab angestoßen mit
tchenen tvsien und so das habe ich
angefangen ja ja jetzt musst du wieder
eins
vorschlagen wir könnten m vielleicht ein
Thema was ich schon im LP oder so
besprochen habe das vielleicht
interessant ist wenn man es mal zu zweit
od so diskuti ich komme drüber verdammt
Leitern da wenn ich da dran lang hangle
dann dann geht das nicht Gott jetzt bin
ich so weit unten wie du so mach mach
mal vor mach mal vor gleich gleich
gleich Thema mach erst mal vor so dann
da genau und wie kommst du jetzt den
einen Block weiter h wie machst den das
ich Fall einfach rüber gehen einfach
rübergehen es geht bei mir gar nicht was
hast du für ein
Minecraft frag mich nicht das geht bei
mir
nicht du musst dich do einfach rüber
Angeln man ist doch nicht
schwer
dass ich Schift gedrückt habe die ganze
Zeit kann das nichts werden weil ich
wollte nicht runterfallen von den
Leitern also Schift gedrückt und deshalb
ach so ja was für ein Thema verdammt B
ein Thema raus warte wir hatten nie eins
bezüglich Animes was sagst du zu Animes
schaust du gerne mal gesehen Schau oder
meinst du jetzt irgendwie so Mangas oder
sowas auch oder nur Fernsehen ne eher
nur Animes an sich die du so kennst was
ich die auch laufen sei RTL 2 sei sonst
wo sei auf ja Moment ich hab es gerade
geschafft von daher soll ich dir mal
wieder ein Checkpoint aufmachen guck mal
ich dich sogar zu gr zu Grunde wenn ich
hier
aufnehme also Animes habe ich früher
richtig viel gesuchtet vor allem sowas
wie One Piece oder halt Pokémon oder
so Pokémon kann man auch als Anime
verstehen oder ja aber es eher so ein
kinderanime ja komm ich war ze als ich
das geguckt habe ja da war ich auch ich
habe früher auch geschaut aber das ist
dann eher so kinderanime geworden
gewesen ähnliches auf müsstest oder wenn
ich aufziehen müsste hätten wir One
Piece Bleach Naruto shipuden und fairy
tale im Moment und Detektiv con Detektiv
connon ist richtig geil ja ich habe alle
vol alle 650 Folgen angeschaut was ja
gibt es schon seit 15 Jahren oder so und
650 Folgen hinten wir da das ist auch
noch mal eine Kiste mit den Diamanten
hast den schon gesehen oder so hier
wohering nö ich glaube nicht ich bin
gerade schon wieder ganz oben und mach
die gleich wieder ein Checkpoint auf du
bist glaub noch nicht mal durch den
anderen Checkpoint durch oder Kiste mit
Diamant gefunden nee ich bin noch nicht
durch aber ich habe hier auch gerade
versucht mal wieder das selbst auch noch
durchzumachen muss läuft Moment ganz gut
oh Mann ich bin wieder runtergefallen na
egal komm doch mal rüber hier aber was
gut ist oder sind die Kinofilme von
detive con übrigens die sen echt genial
finde ich Kinofilme von äh bei einem von
Pokémon habe ich mal geheult weil ich
den so geil fand also nicht weil ich ih
geil fand sondern weil Pikachu gestorben
ist Pikachu
gestorben danachher jetzt war total
verletzt und hat sich dann gestritten
mit Pikachu voll komisch mein Gott ich
weiß gar nicht wo die nächste stage ist
ich ren gerade irgendwo rum ja ich bin
einfach schon so weit ne bist du durch
nächsten Checkpoint durch bist habe ich
dir schon wieder neuen aufgemacht du
bist gerade ziemlich weit weg ne aber du
kommst gerade auf mich zu das sehe ich
ja ja aber ich weiß nicht wo der nächste
ist
irgendwie stage 86 stage
87 hier nee oder ich weiß nicht wo ich
habe einfach nur ein Checkpoint
aufgemacht aber es schon wieder eine
ziemlich große stage also groß räumig
Jump onto the
ladder ach da ist
er Jump onto that platform Redstone
Torch Jump slightly to so that you will
not fall guck mal ich bin eine ganze
Dinge zu als du aber das wird richtig
schwer für dich na okay geht
nein ach oh mann das war so schwer und
dann so da jetzt auf die Leiter ja keine
Ahnung guckst du immer noch viel Animes
ja Moment also wenn täglich was ich was
rauskommt sei donnerstags nauto shipuden
schau ich eigentlich immer in der Regel
an gleich auf japanisch mit deutschem
Untertitel was ist denn eigentlich so
dein Ablauf von dem Tag Ablauf von dem
Tag mitten in der Woche einfach wann ist
wann stehst du auf was machst du dann
und so na bis 5 Uhr bist du am Arbeiten
halt von morgens von von W stehst auf
6:30 Uhr also bin ich etwa zu Hause dann
gucke ich erstmal wegen youtube mal PC
an lad die nächsten Folgen hoch bei dir
kommen Folgen nicht um 5 vor Uhr 5 deine
Folgen kommen nicht vor 5 Uhr nee nee
nee war ich kommt immer abends dienstags
Bleach gibt seit neu weil ein nicht
weiter fortgeführt wird und außerem weiß
nicht wo ich hinchampen muss jetzt
gerade ja hier darüber ach
so ja was machst du dann also nach
Arbeit um 5 Uhr wann gehst du pennen
wieder pennen oh das ist warieriert
teilweise zwischen 12r und 1 Uhr unter
der Woche und wann wo arbeitest du also
nicht wo sondern als was das
interessiert die Leute ja vielleicht
auch weiß nicht habe ich schon glaube
drei Trillionen mal angesprochen im
Let's Play oder so Feuerwehrmann gefühlt
nee Feuerwehrmann
h
irgendwiendwie kommst du auf
Feuerwehrmann weiß ich nicht hast du mir
das nicht mal gesagt nein oh Gott
Feuerwehrmann ja Feuer nein runter
gefallen ja
Feuerwehrmann war
anderin keine Ahnung als was denn ich
bin bundesfreiwilligenienstleister er
leistender also sowas wie
ersatzzivildienst den ich nicht mehr
machen muss sondern einfach nur
freiwillig
ma und wie verdienst du den dein Geld da
kriegst du halt nicht viel dadurch aber
so ein Taschengeld so so ein Alibi
Taschengeld die müssen uns ja auch was
geben als freiwilligen Dienstleistende
ja das ist nicht sonderlich viel es ist
wirk natürlich noch Youtube ja ach so ja
stimmt die Millionen von Youtube darf
man nicht über vergessen wann haben wir
das angesprochen in welcher Folge war
die bei Dir oder war die auf meinem
Kanal ich glaub die war bei dir ich h
gerade fest meine ja jetzt geht hast
wieder dann war es irgendwie die letzte
Folge also wer wissen will was wir mit
unserem Youtube Geld anstellen die ja ja
GZ wichtig alle anschauen ja ja nee und
das ist in einem Behinderten Heim für
geistig behinderte Menschen und die
haben verschiedene Arbeitsbereiche dort
ich bin da in der gnerei
oh interessant
handpflanzen nee die haben wir da nicht
haben tak wollt einer mal
anbauen ich habe so ich habe so gesagt
hier zu zu gruppenleit hier guck eine
colapflanze Pflanze wä ihm
lieber oh mann schaff das nicht ich hab
es vohin geschafft jetzt bin ich wieder
komplett
unten okay noch nicht komplett
aber ach Mist M M ich freue mich schon
wenn 5 Minuten guck bin ja hier guck mal
wo ich bin ja wo bist denn du ja da war
ich ja vorin auch schon ach bin ich ja
wieder runtergefallen
genau da wo du stehst bin ich
runtergefallen ach so nee das ma ich
nicht runterfallen ist blöd mach das mal
das voll cool macht voll Spaß ja ich mer
B gerade runtergefallen
nein ich hole Dich gleich ein ich Bee
mich gerade sowas von nein ich war kurz
verchluss letzter
Sprung ich wollte gerade sagen hier ich
ma dir mal Checkpoint auf aber
nein ja warte ich schaffe das ja jetzt
ich Brau kein Checkpoint ja guck mal wo
ich schon wieder
bin sag n die stopppow 10 Minütchen ja
10 Minuten 10 Minuten 10 Minuten ganz
genau 10
Minuten so schauen wir mal wo ich bin
nein ach nein bitte nicht auch jetzt bin
ich wieder hier am Arsch du bist am
Arsch da musst du da weggehen oh jetzt
bin ich da auch noch runtergefallen Bo
ich war gerade so gut
und ich erst letzter
Sprung bist du jetzt schon wieder nee
bist du nicht W wieder hin ich überhole
dich
gleich ja ja das will ich sehen dass du
mich
überholst bin direkt hinter
dir okay das W jetzt ein wettrinn ja na
klar los geh
überholt wenn du runterfällst dann würde
ich sagen lol
har so jetzt hier jetzt hier jetzt hier
ne guck mal wo ich
bin ich mach dir mal ein Checkpoint auf
ne ich habe schon wieder geschafft du
hast mir noch kein einziges Mal
Checkpoint aufgemacht guck mal ich bin
hinter dir hab auch geschafft m ach mann
so jetzt müssen wir da rum jumpen siehst
du jetzt geht's wieder hier ne geht
schon ziemlich das ist die vorletzte
stage in diesem kompletten dingenen wir
haben das ganze jetzt fast in einem Part
durch durchgekriegt ja oder in zwei ja
warum nicht geht doch h wo muss man denn
hier hoch das weiß ich nicht einfach
Malm drum rumlaufen klappt schon ja soll
do hier drauf jumpen oder jump across ah
da
ach
da und hier und hier und hier dann da
auf die Leiter jump to where the
Redstone torches ach
da
okay Redstone torches kan ich ein Schild
oder so stellen ja das sieht man Messer
also stehen eh überall Schilder jump to
where the child ist das sind so 2000
Schilder
okay
ist wie ich auf
sch ist schtes
Kind springe dahin wo das Kind
ist g mal wo ich bin aber ich weiß jetzt
nicht wohin
jetzt h
ah
da turn
around turn around and jump onto the
next platform okay ich bin schon
ziemlich
weit tendenziell dann auch doch nein
bist du nicht ich mach dir mal g ich
mach dir mal Checkpoint auf
ne ach J wie ich diesen Spruch liebe ich
mach dir mal den und den auf ich achte
jetzt übrigens immer konsequent auf die
Uhr weil auf dich da irgendwie kein
Verlass mehr ist ja wir sind schon bei
17 Minuten B wir sind schon bei
16 sind bei 13,7 ja ich habe Wieders
bekommen ich kann nicht ja das ist voll
schlimm vor allem weil Leute als was von
einem
wollen
Land und the block ist ja mach mal ich
habe es gerade schon fast geschafft ich
stamp noch mal runter aber egal wo
geht's h noch mal raus irgendwie ich
habe dir da gerade auf jeden Fall ein
Checkpoint geholt so viel wo es
rausgt ja das ist natürlich schlecht
ach
da 14
15 wir sind jetzt wo W wo Check ach da
16 da so oh man ich bin falsch
gesprungen ach egal ich bin kurz hinter
dir gerade gewesen ja ich bin noch
gerade falsch gesprungen
blöd so wohin denn jetzt da auf jeden
Fall hoch und also verwinkelt aber die
Challenge hier gefällt mir dann eher als
die vorherigen muss ich sagen ja ich
find auf jeden Fall auch cool ohne
irgendwelche Pistons oder so schon ganz
chillig Jump hier ich hab Diamanten
gesehen cool darst aber nicht abbauen
schade wo muss ich jetzt hin laufen
hä ich glaube ich bin wieder irgendwo
runtergelaufen wo ich gar nicht
runterlaufen sollte ah doch da kann sein
Jump hier then turn around ach
dahin turn around wieder Jump ab hier
nein ach ich bin runtergefallen unten ne
ich bin jetzt da wo man auf dem Land und
the block with sign ja ich bin hinter
dir sogar noch oh Gott ja ich binst eben
gerade nein jetzt Hack ich auch noch e
sind schon wieder bei über 15
Minuten ja super auf
dieeguckt ja wir könnten die Folge jetzt
beenden sein du willst unbedingt noch
die Challenge completen weil das nämlich
die letzte diesem Level nein wir beenden
das jetzt habe kein Bock so lange
hochzuladen bin jetzt schon froh wenn
ich die oder wir machen jetzt eben noch
schnell
ich konzentriere mich jetzt einfach dann
schaffen wir das jetzt eben
noch so und
hier nein ach komm wir brechen das jetzt
ab wir sehen uns in der nächsten Folge
beim spark of Phoenix in erneut Bauer
die kommt dann übermorgen J und dann m
natürlich auf die letzte auf für heute
sein und ja wir sehen uns dann einfach
im nächsten Part bei Spark übermgen auf
seinem Kanal online und wenn alles wenn
ich schlage ich dich ja schlag mich dann
einfach ruhig und Tschüss und dann ich
geb das Schlusswort einfach mal dir ja
schchüsen Tschüss